[Music]
yo girloc she in my
DM on the gang brand new
BM brand new baby mama and the Beamer
that the gun play with schamer I stay
scheming shooting in the gym oh that's
your girlfriend she knew him you know my
[__] say hell no but I'mma hit that
[__] raw dog it's Lefty G play i' been a
pimp and I'mma saying I'm really rich
I'm really
him all right look let's go again I am I
am I am I'm really him call me Lefty G
on the game like violins God all these
fo singing to the [__] pit cuz I
empty out them Clips on the [__]
opposite I'm a sick dog baby I'll be
rolling in Mercedes man I'm driving all
these girls up in b par so
crazy and I could really change your
life baby go and play in the wi sa and
baby girl she get her feet done call me
left G play on the game they want to
become the best rapper but they don't do
it like me it's notan I don't really
give a [__] I bought my [__] some
sailon she put the sailor on on I don't
really give a [__] baby girl turn me on
but I'm a player though and I'm going to
get all these [__] because I'm
[__] getting rich [__] what's your
digit I give a damn ha a [__] and I'm a
ratchet they call me lefty gun play and
I stay blasting I'm in the field I'm so
cold I'm like basting Robins 31 Flavors
come and ask him I'll stay robbing [__]
if I never ain't hot I don't really give
a damn do a robbery why not like how
long will I stay hot in the rap game I
want to be forever but I'll just do a
robbery man hey yo hold let's change the
beat up can we change the beat up I'll
go forever hey do many men 50 r that be
that was hard I said some hard [__] that
[__] was hard was hard as that was hard
I came up with that [__] right now my
head he gave me the [__] like man
slow beads let me get some 100 100 BPM
oh 100 BPM all right yo yo do uh stupid
young stupid young Mando yeah stupid
young Mando instrumental some West Coast
[__] like come on West Coast like low or
EAB do I'll do that one stupid young
let's do for young all right
look hey look turn more yeah all look I
do it like this catch a case on stit
that's Mando pull it to the crib in your
sand I don't give a [__] want the animal
I'm from Bimal Styles Mando lety G play
like Orlando hit him with the Majesty
can she can't take all the dick
an
an shout out I broke this bitch's ankles
call me Kurt ankle I'll be grabbing on
her an ankles I don't give a [__] got it
on like you can't tell call me lefty gun
play on the gang and I give him shells
like a to I got shells in the damn clip
call me lefty gun play on the gang I
really yeah on the gang I really Rampage
[__] knocking [__] out and I do damage
[__] look lefty gun play I've been a
fool I've been po Middle School kill the
instrumental Man is cool I told I [__]
said I'mma give a full full dick and I
pull out going to play when I pull out
pull out with two forign though on the
game your [__] was boring bro and that
[__] getting on my nerves [__] rap I
rather put in work I give a [__] about
the rap BR bounce on my neck got these
[__] all wet B Park set selling
ounces in the set make them bounce and
they way I make them bounce to the
ounce zapping Roger at your house
got your baby mama's ass Che call me
lefty gun play everywhere call me daddy
damn daddy roll bound straight go the
ruler got a [__] she used to work at
Hood got a [__] that work at s on the
gang she had a LD F me out little [__]
right now I don't give a [__] it's on
sight now he don't want to fight now
with that night now I don't give a [__]
I'm [__] fight I wolf is that
shooting whatever you want [__] you
could go and get the sa on cuz I could
really change your life baby on the gang
and I could put you in that new Mercedes
gang Gango shout out to Kurt Angle and
Lain bail bondsman godamn it I'm say I
don't know what the [__] I said that was
hard what beat you want I want
[__] um ebk jbo type beat just
type in E ebk jbo type beat IBK man on
the set he's hard he's super hard shout
out to Stockton put his Hard
instrumental his hard as go to hey put
put a a free MAX
instrumental evk let me get in my
feelings see if here I'll see some
personal [__] free MAX free MAX the
instrumental I got it did you find it
free
MAX see he got it come on damn I'm kill
this [__] can we turn one light off turn
it up all right
look all
right this for my homie though look yeah
and only real ones can feel my pain
shorty want to be a thug up in the range
40 Glock with them slugs man I was
really [__] honey man I be [__]
all these
[__] we a down [__] no
[__] baby girl what's your digit been
in jail so long I don't know how to kick
it call me left I'm like old school I
don't give a [__] this a pro to Pro CL
sh which one call me Lefty local with
them big guns big guns big guns I got
big guns Pacman the gun man I on the run
I don't give a
[__] [__] I rather put them
working and I'm always [__] serving
still serve you a n like where they at
pulling up in the fras with big straps
pull up in the outou in the fras like
where they at I'm hopping out in no
money you know I'm stra call me lefty
gun play I'mma hit it from the back I'm
a sick dog OT baby I'm just a superstar
and I don't really give a [__] I've been
maneuvered for in cars me left the gun
play [__] really Bing now I don't
really give a [__] them [__] is really
calling now but where the [__] you at
when I was out there sitting down yeah
feel same if I was sitting down I catch
a f with my homie going round for round
and if my homie knock me out then I'mma
gun him down scan this P then don't give
a [__] that's the whole la how I give it
up them [__] is mad cuz probably want
to [__] yeah but they can never [__]
with me yeah and it's my old stun yeah
it feel like just a
robbery yeah I got this money out of
nothing you suck at rapping they call me
lefty gun play you f ain't capping and I
don't give a [__] you like Captain
Captain America saving all of these
[__] man I keep a rich [__] a [__]
man Rich Homie Quan getting rich man
yeah Rich Homie on my neck man they call
me lefty gun play on the gang I'm in the
set I'm a super when I'm banging in the
set I'm a slide and Dodge dangles with
the clip and get them wet I'mma W them
up where you from let me know what's up
I'm right here with and they already
know what's up call me [__] I'm the
sick [__] catch me on with the up in
the
FR she pretty [__] in Fr missionary
position com and get me W Dam it's hard
off the top of the head I don't know
what the [__] is you said that sh was
hard yeah none of these rappers could
really rap off the top of their head
like that dog that [__] was hard let me
get a copy of that [__] you got it
brother he thank you man thank you man
for having me it was a hard yeah you can
have it then now [__] that's your money
no you're my boy no our money our money
let's get a flip hey hey you just
watched another freestyle brought to you
by the good Folks at LRG goddamn it
shout out to LRG all right go use the
promo code bootleg right now on their
website l-r-g.com say 40% off that
checkout 40% % off at checkout use that
promo code and we got another freestyle
coming ASAP